حول هذه التطورات والهجمات العسكريه ينضم
الينا من عمان الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي اللواء فايز دويري لواء فايز
مرحبا بك معنا اذا بالنسبه لك كمتابعه
عسكري اي الجبهات الان تشهد حراكا وتوترا
اكبر بالنظر الى اعلان الطرفين تحديدا في
الطائرات المسيره التي يتم اسقاطها
يعني في ظل تعثر المعارك التقليديه وهي
المعارك المتعارف عليها تاريخيا وعدم قدره
اي من طرفي الصراع على تحقيق انجازات
حقيقيه والانجازات في هذه المعارك تعني
استعاده السيطره على مناطق في ارض الخصم
في ظل هذا التعثر نجد ان المسار الاخر
للمعارك هو الذي يتم التركيز عليه وانت
اشرت بنوع من الاصابه الى ذلك وهو اللجوء
الى القسم المدفعي القصف الصاروخي استخدام
الطائرات المسيره ماذا يعني ذلك يعني ان
القدرات الكامله لدى الوحدات المقابله لم
تعد تؤهلها ما لم يحدث مفاجاه على تغيير
الواقع الميداني اي بمعنى اخر ان الحرب
بدات تدخل في نفق حرب الاستنزاف لعدم وجود
القدرات لكن يبقى هناك نقاط اشتعال لا
نستطيع تجاوزها نجد في جبالوجيا القوات
الاوكرانيه تحاول ان تتقدم باتجاه توكمت
في منطقه باغموت نجد الحديث يدور حول
بلدات في الشمال والجنوب من في منطقه
ليمان نجد ان القوات الروسيه تتحدث عن
انجازات ولو كانت محدوده للوصول الى نهر
اوسكار ولكن بصوره عامه اصبح المسار
الموازي للمعارك هو الذي يعلو والذي يخضع
للتغطيه الاعلاميه والمتمثل جماعه شرق في
ثلاثيه ابعاد القصف المدفعي الصاروخي
الطائرات المصريه
عسكريا مفهومه
تحديدا لا يوجد سلاح ولا يمكن ان تشكل
ابرمز مثلا اضافه وتغيير نوعي في المعركه
الرئيس السابق دائما تصريحاته عنيفه
وتصليحات تصريحاته صادمه ولكنها لا تنسجم
برايي الشخصي مع ارض الواقع هو يتحدث عن
صدام ما حلف الناتو هل يتحدث عن صدام غير
مباشر ام مباشر اذا كان يتحدث عن صدام
الغير مباشر هذا الصدام منذ سنوات اذا
يتحدث عن صدام مباشر لا يوجد لدى روسيا
طرف القوه والقدره التقليديه للدخول في
ذلك الصراع اما الحديث عن الدبابه افرانس
يعني تم تضخيم هذا الحدث الان نعم ابرامز
افضل دبابه في العالم لكن ابرامز عندما
يتم الحديث عن 31 دبابه في المجمل مجموعه
قتال يعني ويعني وصول الدفعه الاولى 11
دبابه فريق قتال ماذا يمكن ان يسند لها
ماذا يمكن ان تفعل انا لا اقلل من قدرتها
القتاليه ولكن حتى تؤدي دورها الق تحدث
تغيير يجب ان يكون العشرات الفرقه متوسطه
الفرقه رغم التباين بين دوله واخرى اكثر
من 300 دبابه اللواء اكثر من 100 دبابه
مجموعه القتال اكثر من 30 دبابه لاحداث
تغيير الدراماتيك استراتيجي يجب ان لا يقل
عدد الدبابات عن 300 دبابه في الحد الادنى
وهذا غير متاح اما انا اتحدث عن عشره و11
دبابه اصلا لا استطيع استخدامه من ادوار
الحقيقيه الادوار الهجوميه سارجع في
تطويعها لتستخدم في الادوار الدفاعيه
لصد الهجمات والهجمات المعاكسه ليس اكثر
من ذلك شكرا جزيلا لك
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي من عمان